För det kändes som det mest rätta svaret, men någonstans vill jag påverka branschen.
Jag vill få liksom...
Det är ett sådant problem med oligopolet.
Alla pratar om det när ingen hör liksom.
Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om dig själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Det är rätt sjukt att ni, vad sa du, omsökt en 160 minuter.
Jag är ju chanobilgenerationen, jag kan inte ta...
Du vet, vem är du typ?
Det låter inte så jävla verkligt.
Du har redan dessbra ord.
Ni har inga sura kolleger, ni bråkar aldrig och det finns inga tulliga ögonblick.
Ja, nu kanske jag får skit för detta men jag säger...
Jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Idag välkomnar vi Jens Thulin från Mylla till podden Make Sweden Stronger.
Tjena Jens.
Tjena Johan.
Du berättar det här, du sitter i kanske den mest avancerade podds-setappen som jag har varit med om när jag spelar in.
Jag har ju intervjuat många, liksom mediefolk och liknande, de har ju ofta sämsta setupen och min fördom här nu när du ska komma hit som lantbrukare är att du ska spela in lite mer ruff oldschool men det här ser ju bra ut.
Ja men kul, jag har varit lyckligt oveten att detta var så fancy men det är väl schysst.
Jag berättade kort innan vi drog igång att jag har slavat bort mina eller min pappa körde över mina grymma pälterlurvar som jag annars hade tänkt använda.
Jag tycker att jag brukar ett schysst konferens på dem istället.
Ja men det ser fint ut, vi hoppas att ljudet verkligen är med människor idag och du driver, vi kan väl säga sen, du driver mylla men du driver bara mylla utan du är en äkta lantbrukare skulle jag kunna säga så.
Du driver lite fler grejer.
Ja precis, i Grunebotten är jag en lantbrukars son.
Inom familjen driver vi fem stycken olika gårdar.
Följ och uppväxt i en liten by utanför Malmö som heter Vismalöv och vi är snart 40 års ålder och har inte flyttat därifrån innan.
Det är typiskt, det kanske är det som är äkta bunden.
Hur är det med dejtingutbud på sådana här marknader?
Det är tufft, jag har fått hämta min fru hela vägen från Blekinge.
Finns det en anledning till att bondesökifru existerar?
Det är någon som tänkte till innan.
Den enda vännen jag hade, det var den enda som fanns.
Det är Frank som driver en av, han är kund till Mylla idag, han är bagare i byn.
Vi har ett stenungsbagere i byn och det var min kompis.
Det var för att utbudet, nu klickar vi väldigt väl men hade vi inte gjort det, då hade jag inte haft någon vän.
Jag tänker också, det var bara ett år men när jag var liten bodde jag i en liten, kallar man det en plats kanske jag ska säga.
Jag kan inte säga by för vi var liksom trefamiljer, men då, min styrfarsan är gammal lantbrukare, eller han, inte lantbrukare, han var väl bonde, för de hade ju bara kossor.
Så då hade de massa kossor och det var ju vi, och så var det en annan familj.
Och nu var ju de schyssta, men det var en jävla tur, annars är det ju jävligt tråkigt där på vintern alltså.
Ja men lite så, det kanske finns en anledning att ganska många av de här Ashbergs granfädenprogram var ju i Skånsk landsbygd.
Exakt, man ser varann varje dag, då kommer man råka liksom.
Okej, men ni har gård, du har mylla och ni har något seteri.
Vad är ett seteri?
Det låter liksom fint.
Jag har inte något riktigt bra svar.
Det är liksom en stor gård.
Det är enkelt för det.
Ni har en vanlig gård och så har ni en stor gård.
Det är ju inget slott och det är inget herresätet, men det är lite större än en vanlig grundgård.
Sen är det väl en anrik historia.
Sen 1100-talet är här historia från Assertorpsätterisöbret och 1730 ungefär är de flesta byggnader som finns i dag i Uppsådalen på gården.
Blir man lite handikappad i vad man får och inte får göra då?
Man vågar liksom inte riktigt röra i grejer för att det finns alltid en historia bakom.
Det är lite som att bygga hus i Italien, man vill inte gräva.
Nej, framförallt ska man inte fråga för mycket innan man gör det.
Jag fattar, man ber om ursäkt efteråt eller så säger man inte något till någon.
Det får ni själv säga.
Vi ska egentligen prata om Mylla, för det är det som folk som lyssnar på den här podden känner mest till.
Men kan du förklara lite vad Mylla är för någonting?
Ja, men visst kan jag göra det.
På Mylla bygger vi en marknadsplats och ett verktyg för små och medelstora livsmedelsproducenter som vill sälja sina råvaror, livsmedel och produkter med så få mellanhänder som möjligt direkt till konsumenter.
Och ta större kontroll över hela processen, hela försäljningen, varumärket, prissättning, distribution, logistik och marknadsföring.
Annars är en bransch väldigt koncentrerad till ett fåtal stora aktörer, den här oligopolsituationen som vi ser där man får rätta sig efter vad andra tycker och säger och hur man ska göra.
I så ena änden är det mer som en vanlig e-handelslösning och bakom det bygger vi ett verktyg och en plattform som blir ett verktyg för mig som blir smälsproducent helt enkelt.
Men egentligen är det en plattform där du som producent säljer saker direkt till slutkund och tar hand om själva köpet, men tar ni hand om logistiken?
Ja, vi tar hand om helheten.
Jag var med och byggde upp ett bolag innan Mylla där vi bland annat jobbade med retur och reklamationshantering inom traditionell retail, alltså e-handel.
CDON blev vår största kund där rätt tidigt.
Då insåg jag när det kommer till satsningen på Mylla, när vi ska sälja dagligvaror, eller vad vi ska kalla det, mat och livsmedel, så blev begreppet en order, en transaktion och en leverans väldigt betydelsefullt.
Så att du inte får tomaterna på onsdagen och köttet på torsdagen och mjölken på fredagen.
Utan ett och samma ställe med enkelhet.
Så vi hanterar ju hela så kallade fulfillment-delen med kollegor här som springer på lagret och plockar och packar och ser till att grejerna kommer in och helst lika fortare uppåt igen.
Okej men det måste vara en jävla logistikapparat, eller tar ni in allting varje dag så ska ni sampacka?
En jävla logistikapparat.
Det måste väl vara.
Ni började ganska tidigt eller har ni funnits några år?
I nuvarande form är det sedan 2021.
Så fem, sex år har vi hållit på och testat oss fram.
Sen har vi utvecklat den fast modellen flera gånger sen dess.
Målsättningen, det mylla vi bygger idag, men kommissionsbaserad marknadsplats där vi tar betalt från producenterna och tillverkande av bönderna i Odlarna för att de använder plattformen och sen tar vi en katt för transaktionen.
Den modellen har vi haft som målsättning sen vi drog igång, men det är först 2024 som vi fullt ut har efterlevt den modellen.
Så det är bara trögt i början.
Vi har ju ett segment, jag är ju själv lantbrukare som vi inledde med att säga och mylla är ju lösningen på ett egenupplevt problem.
Men ganska många har ju, nu har jag ju kanske lite annorlunda bakgrund, jag har läst sex år på universitetet som inte hade med lantbruket att göra och sen varit med och drivit en start-up från att vi var en handfull medarbetare till en omsättning på nästan en kvarts miljard av de börsnoteringar av det bolaget.
Men där har man ju fått en del erfarenheter såklart och levt lite i två världar.
En då i start-up världen man säger och driva bolag och göra börsnoteringar och sen som lantbrukare hemma på gården.
Och jag har ju en målgrupp idag på mylla som är väldigt, inte för att man ska vara fördomsfull, men jag kan ju bara säga till min pappa till exempel som fortfarande är aktiv.
Det är inte så länge sedan man börjar använda betalkort och smartphone.
Så jag har ju också en målgrupp som inte riktigt vet uppsidan och möjligheten och potentialen med det vi har skapat med mylla, utan man är väldigt traditionell och det finns något som heter Reco-ringar som är lokala Facebook-grupper runt om i landet.
Ja, det finns hundratals och där gör man liksom affär.
Man söker upp konsumenter, man skapar en Reco-ring och sen så är man kanske 10, 20, 30 producenter som gör inlägg där man skriver jag säljer ägg och jag säljer nötsfärs, jag säljer hånung och så vidare.
Sen träffas man på parkeringsplats, allting sker manuellt, väldigt dålig kundupplevelse, extremt dåligt för mig som säljer.
Det tycker man liksom är rätt modernt och fräscht och bra och det är rätt hög tröskel och har varit en ny började rullar på äntligen, men att få mina betalande kunder som är brönder och livsmedelsföretag att förstå värdet och uppsidan av det vi erbjuder, för de har inte riktigt vetat om att de behöver det.
Vad är din argument, eller kanske snarare, vad är motargumenten då när du kommer och säger sälj här istället, tänker de bara att du lurar dem då eller tänker de att fan det här kommer inte funka eller att det blir ingenting av det, eller vad är motargumenten?
Motaargumenten är väl att jag tror att vi bygger något som är långsiktigt stabilt.
Vi bygger ett bolag som ska finnas om 15-20 år, det är ingen snabb raket, vi ska bygga här nu, sen ska vi göra en exit och sen sticker jag.
Det är väl just det där att du behöver investera tid och ha lite tålamod.
Men skulle vi växa mylla väldigt mycket snabbare, då skulle vi sätta upp en helt vanlig retail-modell.
Vi köper in råvaror och råvaror från Crete och Pleti, sen kör vi ett påslag där och sen säljer vi det vidare.
Men jag har varit väldigt...
Målbilen från alla första början, det har dragit att bygga motsatsen till det.
Det finns redan så många aktörer som gör det, det är liksom ICA-Q på Axfoods modell bygger på dig.
Ju mer jag kan pressa i den änden, ju mer jag kan sätta mitt eget varumärke på, desto bättre marginaler kan jag hålla.
Jag vill ju ha ett alternativ till den modellen, så vi skulle växa snabbt och komma upp i 100 miljoner dekter.
Då hade jag ju bara ringt runt och sagt, om du är tomatodlar, tjena Joel, jag skulle vilja köpa två pallar tomater, vad är det bästa priset du har?
Sen har du sagt, ja du kan få dem för detta, sen hade det varit deal eller ingen deal, sen har jag sålt dem vidare.
Sen hade vår relation stannat där, då hade det faktorerat, jag hade betalt.
Här handlar det om att nu ska du vara med på plattformen, du ska vara med och förändra någonting, skapa ett nytt beteende, både just dig som säljer tomaterna, men också just konsumenten som ska köpa dem.
Argumentet skulle jag säga, det är väl att, vi har hållit på så pass många år nu, vi ser att det funkar, det börjar röra på sig, omsättningen stiger, antalet intressenter vill sälja via plattformarna ökar, och konsumenter som hittar till oss ökar.
Men det kräver en del från dig, du behöver lägga ner tid, det är inte en ren marketplace, för vi lägger oss i hur produktbilderna ser ut, vi lägger oss i hur produkttexterna ser ut.
I en vanlig, hade det varit en annan bransch, hade det varit helt naturligt att om du ska sälja dina tomater, antingen är det för att göra riktigt schyssta produktbilder och produkttexter själv, eller som fick du anlita någon, och då har vi extremt fördelaktiga priser för att hjälpa dig som tomatodlar med det.
Men där är man ganska snål och okunnig på vad saker och ting kostar.
Fast att vi tar fram en professionell studiefotograferad bild på dina tomater för 2,95 spänn, vilket är under halva marknadspriset.
Det är bara gud 2,94 spänn, det är jag har ju en hyfsad rekamera här på min gamla Nokia.
Jag gör det själv liksom, det är en mentalitet.
Man räknar åt sin egen tid, man är inte riktigt uppdaterad alltid vad alla kostnader runt omkring KÖ, vad de faktiskt är och vad marknadspriset är.
Så nu har vi utvecklat AI-stöd och liknande i plattformen så är du inte så duktig på texter, så räcker det att du skriver 10-15 stödord kring din verksamhet och kan skriva det, tredje generationens familjelantbruk, det är ekologiskt, det är gräsbetat, det är vad det nu är.
Och så skapar plattformen en schysst beskrivning av din verksamhet till exempel av dina produkter.
Men där är helt klart, vi kunde ha valt en betydligt enklare väg om jag säger så men samtidigt så är det många andra som har gjort det redan och det är inte det som behövs.
Men är detta liksom ett passionsbolag?
Är det sprunget ur någon sorts irritation eller det framstår ju nästan så liksom utifrån?
Ja, hur ska jag uttrycka?
Det är klart att det drivs av ett oerhört mycket passion.
Hade jag bara brytt mig av hur mycket pengar jag skulle tjäna så hade jag kanske valt något annat.
För det är klart att det är utmaningar.
Men är det här vi kan göra stort avtryck?
Ja.
Behövs det förändring?
Kan du kapitalisera på det?
Kan du bli jävligt förmögen på det?
Ja, det tror jag faktiskt.
Du måste ha hyfsat välfylld kassa och du måste ha extremt mycket pannben att tålamod.
Men tänk dig en bransch som omsätter över en miljard om dagen med en penetration på typ 99,9 procent.
Det finns tre aktörer som kontrollerar över 90 procent av marknaden.
Är det plats för fler?
Efterfrågar konsumenten fler alternativ?
Ja.
De här jättarna har väldigt dålig koll på kunddata, konsumentbeteende och så vidare.
De har gigantiska kundklubbar och lojalitetsprogrammen.
De kan inte hantera datan.
Så att det mylla på sikt kommer att kunna tjäna pengar på de här föruttryckade sakerna.
Det är ju datainsamlingen vi gör.
När vi kan börja prognostisera, när vi kan koppla samman efterfrågan och produktionen, när vi kan sätta dem i relation till man.
Så att producenter vet vad de ska producera.
Kanske får kommitt med en trend i förväg.
När jag odlar detta så har jag redan köpare.
Redan nu har jag kört igenom 80 000 unika kunderordrar.
Det är inte så mycket data sett i dagligvaruhandeln, men det börjar bli ganska mycket ordrar sett i vår nisch.
Det är ingen alla vill ha, svenskt, småskaligt, kvalitativt.
Men det är ingen som vill ta i det med ton.
Där börjar det bli ganska intressant vad vi ser för trender och hur vi kan börja använda den datan på ett smartare sätt.
Vad är det som är knepigt för att jag fattar att det tar lite tid att omborda folk och det blir ju lite annat köpbeteende för mig som kund, men det ligger ju jävligt rätt i tiden.
Man ska handla svensk, man ska handla lokalt, man ska handla av ett riktigt företag och du förstår vad jag menar, där du vet vilket företag.
Det tickar ju väldigt många boxar hos väldigt många människor.
När du berättar din idé, det är väl inte ofta du får hat för din idé, det är inte så att du har startat ett, jag vet inte, någon sorts nikotinbolag.
Utan det är ju någonting som resonerar med ganska många och även om det inte är så många som kanske jobbar med landsbruk idag, så finns det ju många som ändå har någon i släkten som har varit i den.
Så man vill gärna förknippas med det, eller man har någon sorts romantiserad bild av det i alla fall, tänker jag.
Men varför, med all kärlek, varför växer det inte fortare?
Varför är inte detta ett bolag som verkligen så här, som folk verkligen hoppar in i?
Är vi så jävla fast i vårat sätt liksom?
Ja, alltså den personen jag är svarar ju på den frågan med att vi inte har gjort det tillräckligt bra i det.
Ja okej, vad är det du menar ni inte har gjort särskilt bra då?
Ja, men nästan helt enbart i den så är det så här att alla, om jag får generalisera lite, men du är inne på det själv Joel där med, men liksom vi prickar nästan alla.
Det är makrotrender, det är mikrotrender, det är liksom, ja men det är allt ifrån hälsa, det är självförsörjningsgrad, krisbedelskap, hållbarhet, smak, kvalitet.
Alla de boxarna tickar vi.
Så att jag har ett uttryck som är alla älskar mylar.
Det är väldigt få som kritiserar det vi gör eller säger att det inte behövs.
Och hade bara alla som älskar mylar handlat så hade vi varit ett miljardbolag.
Alltså var jag än kommer, jag var i Stockholm förra veckan, och folk kommer fram och liksom, du har typ Sveriges viktigaste jobb som gör hejar, och jag tipsar alla, jag vet, alla bara, så bara, okej men kul, är du kund?
Man bara, nej.
Det var jobbigt.
Vi jobbar ju med det liksom dag in och dag ut, vecka efter vecka, månad efter månad.
För vi, uppenbarligen är det tillräckligt för alla älskade, mer eller mindre.
Men man liksom tar sig inte tiden att ändra sitt bete.
Det är en sannan i min modifiktion för det är inte dåligt, men jag brukar säga så här på rukar, men ibland är det inte svårt att handla på mylla.
Det är längre ledtiden än om du handlar på den traditionella retailen, men det är jävligt lätt att handla på mylla.
Men det är ännu lättare att skita i det.
Tyvärr är det fortfarande så, men det är som att börja träna, det är inte så svårt att börja träna.
Men det är fan så mycket lättare att, ja jag väntar, ja jag gör det sen.
Och så någonstans blir det en, hur ska jag uttrycka det, man ser mylla som en specialbutik, kanske vi har ju nästan tusen artiklar i sortimentet, du kan handla mer eller mindre alla basvaror från svenska producenter som du behöver.
Från mejeri, skafferi, frukt och grönt och så vidare.
Det som finns i Sverige nu i säsong, det kan du handla.
Så att majoriteten av alla konsumenter som handlar dagligvaror skulle kunna lägga sin bas på mylla.
Du skulle kunna spända 1500-2000 spänn i veckan.
För du behöver afil, du behöver lök, moröt, lite kyckling, ganska många färslande, spaghetti, köttar, sås, köttbullar och så vidare, tacosen.
Den basen skulle du kunna lägga.
Sedan säger jag inte att du ska sluta handla på ICA, Willys och K-pulver, du behöver bananer, mango, sweet chili, sås, toa, pappor, diskmaskin, tabletter och så vidare.
Men det blir liksom så att jag ska testa mylla eller jag glömde handla den i veckan, så jag gör det nästa.
Men du säger ju inte att jag glömde att gå till Ica, så jag, ah, då får jag göra det nästa vecka.
Nej, då gör du ändå liksom.
Det är ett jättehitt argument för varför man ska vänta.
Och då behöver vi göra det ännu bättre och enklare, förklart för att man inte ska kunna göra det varligt.
Sen jobbar vi med någon form av beteendeförändring och det är ju bland det dyraste och svåraste och kanske dummaste man kan ge sig in på.
Men om alla resonerar att det är för svårt att ta sig an det, då blir det inte så himla roliga förändringar här i världen.
Är ni ett privatkundsbolag, är det privatkunder som handlar?
Det måste vara enklare för föreningar och restauranger och liknande att handla från er.
Vi började ju som så många andra om att skjuta hagel.
Vi sprang på alla bollar och kommuner, föreningar, skolklasser som skulle tjäna till skolresan och så vidare.
Det vi gjorde bäst och där vi fick bra feedback och det som funkar bra och där betalningsviljan fanns, det var ju privataktörerna.
Idag av förra årets 24 miljoner i försäljning, så skulle jag säga att ungefär 95% är mot privatpersoner.
Vad är det som är så svårt för de här restaurangköken?
De är väl ändå vana vid att köpa in från lite olika aktörer?
Dels har det varit tuffa år för näringen, ända sedan pandemitiden med uppskjutna skatter och så vidare.
Så där hade det varit tufft.
Många restauranger som hörde av sig var intresserade, de ville ju liksom plocka russin under kakan.
Det var den första sparrisen, det var den svenska saffranen, det var liksom vakteleg och anker på röster.
Det var det som var lite svårt att få tag i.
Men bulkvolymerna som är av intresse för oss att addera till, de är man avtalade med hos de stora grossisterna.
Det kände jag inte till, men jag är till och med en av mina kollegor Peter.
Han har jobbat inom S-group i nästan hela livet, varit med och byggt upp hela den verksamheten.
Sedan, efter han slutade där, så jobbade han sju år på en av de största grossisterna, med fokus på lokalt och småskaligt, och high-end, de riktigt duktiga kockarna runt om i landet.
Men det jag har förstått sedan han började här, det är ju att avtalen med de stora grossisterna, det är liksom väldigt, jag ska inte säga maffialigt, men alltså det är så mycket det går till där.
Det är lite halsmutsigt och det är liksom dealas and wheelas, det är rabatter hit och det är lite sådana bjudresor där.
Det är mycket sådant så att när jag kontaktade de här restaurangerna, Peter började tänkte nu jäklar kör vi, han känner halva krogsvärde och har jobbat på båda sidorna.
Så visade det sig att vi kan inte köpa nötfasen från er, för vår grocist vet ju att vi inte har det märket eller vi har inte från den gården.
Vi har de här kickbacksen och rabattstegarna, skulle de få reda på det?
Nej det går inte.
Hela grejen med myla är ju oftast att det ska synas på menyn i sådana fall.
Carré eller fläsksida från den här gården eller vitkålen kommer från denna odlan.
Det har inte min grocist så det kan inte skrivas på menyn.
Så jag kände att det är så sjukt mycket snack och lite verkstad.
Sen är det också att grocisterna har skämt bort krögarna extremt mycket skulle jag säga dem, och lite sunt bundförnuft.
De kan ju mer eller mindre lägga en år, de är 23 och 30 på kvällen, så ska de ha den 06 på morgonen.
De kör ju flera gånger i vissa områden om dagen och kör alla sju veckor idag.
Tillgängligheten har blivit så god.
Så att det här att vi jobbar med färska råvaror när en producent överdropp med året och en annan mjölkar korn och det tar ett par dagar.
Det passar liksom inte in i deras modell.
Så det var ett råvaror jag hade tänkt mig faktiskt.
Finns det en risk i att du själv är lantbrukare och kanske är lite snäll?
Du vet att ni har byggt upp verksamheten.
Jag säger inte att ni har gjort det, för jag kan ju inte verksamheten, men att man liksom har haft lite för mycket förståelse ut mot producent.
Att man ibland då kanske missar vissa argument mot slutkund då.
Ja, men lite kan det nog vara.
Framförallt har vi varit för snälla mot producenterna i den bemärkelsen att vi hjälper till med väldigt mycket och vi är dåliga på att ha betalt.
För att de är en målgrupp som är väldigt försiktiga med att betala.
Och det som vi har jobbat en del med med Fedja, som du känner också, och direkt när Fedja kom in så sa han så det är så jävla mycket att snacka om bunden hit och dit och det är liksom syn om den och stötta där och så vidare.
Det är bara att bry sig inte.
Det är så jävla fint och romantiskt Jens.
What's in it for me?
Vad tillför du för värde till kunden som ska handla på din marknadsplats och din e-handel?
Och det har vi ju blivit bättre på och kan definitivt bli betydligt bättre på härifrån vi står i dagslaget också.
Så där är du väl inne på någonting som jag tror är ganska sant.
Att vi har tagit så tydligt ställning för producenterna.
Det behövs för det är ju så sjukt oligopolet.
Jag får samtal varenda månad från producenter som behöver prata ut om hur fruktansvärt illa de har blivit behandlade inför handling eller hur det kan gå till och vilka straffavgifter som faller ut om du inte kan leverera de volymerna du har avtalat och så vidare.
Fast att det kanske är en naturlig och god förklaring till varför det har blivit så.
Det gör ju också att man får en jävla dritkraft i det man gör.
Nästan ingen annan vågar stå upp och prata så som jag.
Jag står ibland på konferenser och sitter i panelsamtal och pratar och så vidare.
Det är det typ ingen i branschen som vågar göra.
De kan inte göra det för de riskerar alldeles för mycket.
Det är en rätt stor drivkraft i detta.
Hur ser det ut med den svenska självförsörjning?
Jag tänker att du ändå har lite...
Hur går det för liksom lantbruk och liknande idag?
Startas det någonting?
Nej, det är väldigt få.
Det läggs ju ner mer än ett lantbruk eller livsmedelsföra.
Om du tar ihop det primärproducenter, alla är ju inte indirekt livsmedelsproducenter, men du kan vara spannensodlare och så vidare.
Då läggs det mer än ett av dagen, har det gjort de senaste åren.
Vad betyder det, hur många finns det liksom?
Ett av dagen om vi är 18 miljoner, men är det inte?
Ja, det blir kanske pass på den frågan.
Vi kan klippa in som en liten sån här.
Det här är så.
Det är klart att vi spolar bak oss 100 år i tiden och var och varannan sysselsatt sig med gäster.
Det är kring 1% som är sysselsatt in den här näringen i dagsläget.
Så att det är ju, medelåldern är väldigt hög och det är därför många lägger ner också, för det är ingen som tar vid det underifrån.
Det finns ju en anledning till att jag fyller 40 nästa år och inom LRF, som är lantbrukarnas riksförbund, där är man ju ungdom till man fyller 40.
Så det säger en del.
Då sitter vi i barnbordet.
Senast så tror jag det är en styrka också.
Det är en kläntröst som jag brukar säga, med de senaste tre julfesterna så har jag väl hållit i mitt lilla julanförande till mina kollegor och lyft fram styrkan i att vi inte har gått i konkurs.
Det kan låta som en kläntröst, men jag är rätt övertygad om att de förutsättningar vi har haft och den utmaningen vi har stått inför så är det inte många som hade klarat sig genom det.
Det låter kanske som en kläntröst att man inte har gått i konkursen, men det är oerhört många som har försökt.
Just att bygga en enkel plattform eller en app som ska knyta samman producent och konsument, det är ju 20, 30, 40 olika bolag genom åren som har gjort, men det är ingen som har kommit så långt som vi, om du inte har en helt vanlig retailmodell.
Då blir det ju inte precis köp in, sälvvila köp in.
Det har varit tydligt målsen dit ska vi inte.
Där tror jag att det är en styrka att jag själv är producent.
Det är ett egenupplevt problem och det är klart att det ligger en frustration i det som du var inne på, men den långa historien kort är att jag pluggade miljöklimat och hållbarhet på universitetet och läste i en klas där vi var 11 vegetarianer, tre veganer och en till köttätare.
Sedan har jag två och fem gårdar med nötköstproduktion.
Som jag brukar säga, det var inspirerande, frustrerande, provocerande.
Jag lägger mig inte i vad folk äter, det ligger inga värderingar.
Omställningen, ska vi klara 1,5 graders mål och så vidare, vi måste ställa om allt radikalt.
Hur vi äter, hur vi reser, hur vi sparar våra pengar, hur vi äter, hur vi äter gubbet.
Maten är en jättestor del och Johan Rockström, som är en av våra främsta klimatforskare, sa att vi löser vi maten, löser vi planeten.
Där och då blev jag så sjukt inspirerad specifikt av de tre veganerna, för att de hade en drivkraft i att förändra min produktion och de andra i klassens sätt att äta.
Då tänkte jag bara att det kan man ta tillvara på det.
Det är så emotionellt med mat.
Jag sa till dig Joel, du får aldrig mer äta ägg.
Så går du i går.
Det är hög penetration som jag nämnde.
Då bestämde jag mig istället för att så fast den heller att jag ska...
För det är ju aldrig vad det är en kurs som det mest hållbara i ens kan göra.
Det är att ta över de föräldragårdarna med nötskötersproduktion och så lägga ner dem.
Då bestämde jag mig för att göra motsatsen.
Så vi satte upp som målsättning att vi skulle utveckla Sveriges klimatsmartaste nötskötersproduktion.
Vi blev den andra klimatsatsfriade producenten i Sverige och vi bara då kontrakterade ett av de största slakterierna.
Men de jobbar inte med nischprodukter.
Fast att vi hade investerat i sol och vind och elektrifierat, ny foder, start till djuren, ny odlingsteknik.
Med alla de här grejerna så tyckte de att det var fint, bra och härligt.
Det borde fler göra men de jobbar med de stora jättarna.
Vi ska producera så mycket bulkvolym som möjligt rakt in i ett svart hål med pressade priser.
Så vi kan inte hitta någon köpare på ditt specialklimatsatsfriadekött här och så vidare.
Så att du får samma betalt.
Det var ju då, när jag tappade lite, det var helt sjukt.
Vi ska ställa om, matproduktionen är en av de absolut viktigaste branscherna att ställa om.
Men så kan man inte investera.
För jag hade lyckats göra bra affärer på annat håll så att jag kunde finansiera detta.
Det var ganska mycket med hjärt.
Så därifrån blev möjliga en lösning på ett egenloppeläppeproblem.
Då tänkte jag då får jag börja sälja direkt.
Så vi börjar med en egen, väldigt enkel ehandelslösning.
Sedan börjar de kunderna som handlar fråga var köper jag lök, mjölk, fisk, kyckling och mjölk.
På den vägen är det.
Det kanske också är därför det funkar.
Det är därför det inte har gått konkurs.
Det var en riktig säljkanal från start.
Tilliten att någon man får stå sig på.
För är det två duktiga apputvecklare från storstan som har en idé om detta så kan det gå bra men hittills har det inte gjort i alla fall.
Förtroendet hos producenter är av stor betydelse skulle jag säga.
Men den modellen är ju byggd.
Vilken volym krävs för att...
Du sa att ni sålde för typ 24 förra året, om jag hörde det rätt.
Vilken volym krävs för att en sån här affär ska bli lönsam?
För nu har ni gått negativt några år.
Nu vet jag inte om de här 24 är negativa, men jag bara menar vad krävs för att man ska rulla och faktiskt kunna tjäna pengar på det?
Brytpunkten går ungefär vid 70 miljoner i försäljning genom plattformen.
Vilka är de här som investerar i bolaget?
Vad är det de går igång på?
Har de samma passionsdrivna eller ser de det mer som en affär?
Nej, jag skulle ju ljuga men jag säger att jag inte tror att de gör det med passion.
Man vill ju att detta ska lyckas.
För att lyckas är det bra för så många.
Sen så är det vår största investerare Backing Minds som är den första lite mer etablerade spelaren som kom in.
Det var inte så att de bara, ja det var gulligt detta Jens.
Det var en fin historia, det är klart vi stoppar in pengar här.
Det var ju ett stenhårt DD-arbete och det var ju framförallt kronor.
Att kunna bevisa den kommersiella potentialen i detta.
Sen så har jag varit tydlig med alla som investerat i Mylla genom åren.
Att en snabb exit här med en jätteuppsida, det är inte den investeraren.
En växtsäsong pågår upp till 24 månader.
Jag som är djuruppfödare är 36 månader ungefär.
Från att jag betecker en koti, jag har något som jag kan sälja annorlunda än.
Så bara branschen vi jobbar med har rätt långa ledtider.
Det måste man ha en förståelse för.
Jag var ju med i Patrik Blir Engel-podkasten för något år sen och fick med mig en liten investering därifrån.
Då sa jag att det kanske inte är så bra investering.
Man vill ju lyssna på det.
Då vill jag typ inte ha dina pengar.
För då tror du inte på affären.
Det tror jag att de som känner mig vet att det är rätt kul.
Allt blir roligare om man tjänar pengar.
Jag tycker inte det är fuligt att tjäna pengar.
Det var ju lite i den här utbildningen jag gick.
Det var en tabu lite med pengar.
Jag älskar att tjäna pengar.
Jag tycker det är kul med mycket pengar.
Det blir roligare.
Framförallt att det blir lättare.
Det är roligare julfest.
Det är lättare dialoger med producenterna.
Det är roligare när du ska ta in affärer på utvecklar som ska ta fram någon ny funktion i plattformen eller vad det kan vara.
Sen är det en klass.
Jag har aldrig drivit förra bolaget.
Vi byggde upp det i Lönsham från dag ett.
Detta är en relativ ny situation för mina vänner.
Jag har blivit van efter de här åren.
Att ständiga jagandet på pengar har varit fruktansvärt tufft många gånger och frustrerande.
Jag har också levererat på de måltal vi satt upp.
Jag har följt plan ganska väl.
Jag har haft, som alla andra, ett par sakt pengar de här senaste åren.
Hundratals möten med allt från family offices till banker och vc-bolag och så vidare.
De har fått feedback tillbaka.
Så jag kunde sammanfatta till fem-sju genomgående gemensamma nämnare i feedbacken för vad jag ville se mer av.
Sen bockar man av de fem-sju och överlevererar på de flesta.
Kommer tillbaka och bara trodde vi inte, säger de.
Och sen är det bara men.
Och sen kommer det fem-sju nya.
Så har jag hållit på naivt och trott att nu har jag bevisat detta de ville säga.
Så jag men det spelar ingen roll.
Det har väl varit kanske det mest utmanande och att hålla ett motiverat team när vi har sjukt transparent kultur på bolaget.
Så varenda gång det har varit unt om pengar så har alla letat om det.
Jag tror tre gånger sedan vi startade bolaget har jag samlat alla och sagt att nu är det den fjärde i denna månad och det här är inte pengar till löner den 25.
Jag ska göra vad jag kan och ni kan välja att gå hem nu om ni inte vill riskera obetalda veckor och handel fram.
Vill ni så kämpar vi på och ska göra mitt.
Varenda gång har vi knutit näven tillsammans och bara, ja vi kör.
Och som ni sa vi, alla har fått sin löne i tid.
Alla, den 25 genom alla år, utom jag själv.
Jag tänkte säga det.
Men det räknas inte in i mitt.
Men det har varit tufft och det är så klart att där är alla de fantastiska AI-bolag och så som växer fram nu när de på 12 månader helt plötsligt har värderingar som är miljarder.
Där är vi inte och vi kommer inte vara heller.
Sen så tror jag lite så här att vi går också en tid till mötesdag.
Jag vet inte hur du uttryckte det innan Joel men riktiga bolag eller riktiga...
Jag tror att vi kommer komma till en punkt också där man kommer värdesätta på ett helt annat sätt.
Där man har riktiga relationer, riktiga människor.
Som pumpat in miljarder kronor i fotex, som konstiga, syntetiska, sjuk, kass livsmedel.
Och det tror jag att tiden är förbi.
Vi gjorde en crowdfunding i höstas och det var högstrategiskt.
Men då fick vi nästan nionra små delägare i ett separat ägarbolag i Mylla nu.
Jag tror ju att på sikt kommer den trovärdigheten den ger.
Och det är tillhörigheten, commitment, community-byggande.
Jag tror att det kommer att värdesättas också och jag väntar på det här på sikt.
Det har varit så mycket som inte går att ta på värdet.
Det är bara att ha ett högt värde men vad är det som vi värderar så högt?
Så vet vi inte riktigt.
Men jag tror att vi bygger något som kommer att kunna ta på värdet på ett helt annat sätt.
Kan du känna en viss cynism över det där?
Du vet, man ser att andra företag, vi säger ett AI-bolag här, man läste på Breakit här förra veckan, de fick in 300 miljoner, de startade för tre månader sedan.
Så ska de typ göra att man inte ska behöva klicka på stängknappen längre.
Förstår du vad jag menar?
Man får inte bli cynisk heller.
Nej så klart inte men det är klart att det finns, jag vet inte, branschen som sådana är ju också ingenting som är, det är ju inte sexigt på något sätt.
Jag tycker också att det finns, de Aibo-lagen vi läser om på Breakit just nu, det är ju vissa som är så sinnesskult häftiga och som kommer att revolutionera branscher och ta utvecklingen framåt i en sån extrem takt.
Men sen är det vissa basala behov vi har som kommer att ligga kvar, som inte kommer att ersättas av det.
Där känner jag väl lite att vi är, och jag naivt tror att vi kommer att, har vi bara uthålligheten så kommer vi nog att skjuta en ny arrendel.
Du hade Christersson på besök, på gården.
Haha, ser sammanbiten ut.
Jag kan ju tycka att, för det är ju lite grann, Mylla är ju, mår ju på något sätt bra tänker jag av PR.
Alltså det behöver ju komma ut, man behöver liksom få ut dialogen och all, alla frågor om mat och lokalproduktion ska ju på något sätt, liksom försöka pumpas i media.
Jag ser liksom inte nackdelen i det, men du fick en del reaktioner på det där.
Orkar du prata om det eller?
Så farligt var det inte.
Jag är helt inne, folk är säkert många som är sjukt trötta på mig.
För jag försöker i syna så höras på så många ställen.
Folk är trötta på mig också.
Ja men det är ju först när du spyr riktigt mycket på dig själv, som du har synt så hårt tillräckligt mycket, och där är jag inte igen.
Nej, jag tar inte det så hårt.
Alla möjligheter som vi får att synas och höras där det är relevant, det ska ligga i linje med våra värderingar, så ska vi ta den chansen.
Jag fick förfrågan om jag ville ta emot statsministern på ett gårdsbesök för att prata om förutsättningar för svensk livsmedelsproduktion.
För mig var det ett självklart ja.
Sen är det klart, jag tror att jag hade oavsett vilken partitillhörighet.
Men jag vet också att politi har inte så insatt och engagerad aktivt själv.
Men jag har rösträtt och den använder jag mig av såklart.
Det tycker jag är viktigt.
Men mer än så är jag inte så insatt och intresserad.
Men tackar jag och vissa av Myllas kunder, till och med delägare bland de här 900, de var en helt annan partitillhörighet.
De tog det rätt hårt och de tyckte ju att hur fan jag kunde göra så och det är till och med en som har skrivit ditt rasistiska, när har det varit nu, du äcklar mig ens ditt rasistiska någonting.
Och sen skickade de bilder på mig och Ulf Kristersson har visst skrattat i traktorn.
Och sen så en bild på Imi Åkesson och Ulf Kristersson har de skrattat tillsammans.
Och det är klart att bara för att Ulf Kristersson var här så delade jag inte alla åsikter med honom.
Om inte Magdalena Andersson varit på gården så hade jag inte delat alla åsikter med henne.
Men jag ser det som en möjlighet att framföra vår och många små producenters röst på min poppe, den minsta grabbens förskola hade de pratat om det.
Och då hade de sagt att det är han som bestämmer i Sverige, statsministern.
Är det någon man ska försöka påverka så är det ju de som bestämmer.
Det är ju om du är säljare så kontaktar de med beslutsmandaten.
Det är ungefär samma princip.
Så jag tycker inte det är så hårt men det är kul att folk...
Det är fantastiskt att folk bryr sig.
Du är ju svartbältig i LinkedIn.
Men jag försöker ta rygg på det lite och försöker vara aktiv och närvarande.
Men just det inlägget med Ulf Christersson fick mycket engagemang.
Så det är något som folk bryr sig om.
Jag kan bara tycka att det är märkligt när om man har en övergripande åsikt, om man brinner för svensk matproduktion eller att folk ska få välbetalt i startledet på något sätt, så borde det inte spela så jävla stor roll var engagemanget kommer ifrån så länge resultatet blir det samma.
Och det är väl alldeles utmärkt om man kan få över...
Om man nu anser att andra sidan har fel åsikt om det, då är det väl alldeles utmärkt om de kan få rätt åsikt om det.
Det är väl bara positivt.
Jag har svårt att se att folk blir alltid upprörda över olika saker.
Det kommer alltid att vara så.
Det betyder på engagemang att de bryr sig.
Det är bra, sen så hittade jag min fråga till alla de som skrev, det var på Facebook, LinkedIn och Instagram, nån med hela kundtjänst, Hattig Jenny.
Min fråga är tillbaka, jag är till och med delägare, hur kan du göra så här?
Varför investerar du då?
Om du investerar för att du tror på vår vision att göra bra mat mer tillgängligt, få fler svenska producenter att vilja producera mer och våga investera.
Vad är det som gjorde att din investering blev sämre nu eller felaktig på grund av det här besöket?
Det har jag fortfarande inte fått ett bra svar på.
Det är en rindlig fråga tycker jag.
Du sa att Backing Minds var en stor investerare, det är väl Zorra Wimmekranz som jag vill minnas, och hon var med i Draknästet.
Du var med i Draknästet, visst var det så?
Ja, det stämmer.
Var det som på TV eller var det att man sitter där i tre timmar och pratar om helt random grejer och så klipper de ihop för fem sekunder.
Hur riktigt är det?
Ja, men lite så är det ju.
Det jag inte själv trodde var precis så som det var.
Det var att de visste absolut ingenting om vilka bolag som skulle komma.
Och de hade inte fått någon förhandsinformation innan.
För det tror man kanske när man tittar på det.
De har ofta läsa på lite.
Men det var verkligen inte fallet.
När vi kom där till TV-huset och skulle spela in, då var det väldigt noga att du inte fick röra dig.
Så det fanns en risk att de inom paus fick se dig eller gav någon form av möjlighet för dem att känna igen mig och googla upp och kolla och så vidare.
Det är många som har frågat om det och så var det verkligen.
Sen så det som var i själva inspelningen, hade jag fått klippa, hade jag fått lägga mig i klippningen, så tycker man att man är prost på allt själv.
Men jag hade klippt, det var sjukt mycket mer ballar grejer som hände under inställningen, än vad som syntes i det som sändes sen.
Men där blev ju...
Vad var de balla grejer?
Det kom en trollkarl helt plötsligt då?
Det var ändå lite roliga, det blev förhandlingar, det blev lite sura minor mellan drakarna.
Okej, okej.
Jag kom ihåg Lena Apel och skulle låna ut en mini räkna, och de var så trötta på att vi inte kom vid.
Men ta min mini, jag bara kastade ner den, helt snettig kast, bara tilla i golvet, bladriner, flöden.
Det var sådana smågrejer som var lite roliga, och vi till hjälp av en av drakarna för att förhandla mot Sara, det kom inte heller med.
Så det där var lite sånt som kunde ha kommit med som var lite roligt.
Men det som man inte får se sen i tv, det är ju att du står där, nu kommer jag inte ihåg om det var två av tre deals som man tar i hand i inspelningen, som scenen inte blev av.
Alltså det är bara en av tre som blev av eller om det var omvänt, så det är två av tre som blev av.
Men det är ju efter draknästet, för det har bara den tiden på det.
De flesta hade mellan 30 och 40 minuter på sig och det blev en riktig långkör, så vi var inne i 1.45.
Så då var ju produktionen bara skräg, nu måste investerarna, eller entreprenörerna fatta beslut så vi kommer vidare, vi har fler inspelningar.
Men där och då så kom vi överens med Sara, men sen är det ju, sen så börjar det arbetet och hela den processen, så det är en väldigt, väldigt lång bit kvar.
Så när kamerorna släcks, det är ju då arbetet börjar.
Det är bara spännande, man ser det utifrån där, det är kul att höra vad som händer på insidan.
En sista liten, vad ska man säga, först hade ni en ganska procentuellt, även om du säkert hade velat växa med fler miljoner, men procentuellt växte ni ändå på ganska fint.
Sen stagnerade det lite 2024.
Vad var det som gjorde att det gick så jävla bra 2025?
Nu har du varit lite självkritisk här under 50 minuter.
Kan du inte skryta här sista två?
Jag skryter här det sista, nej men det gör jag.
Vi gör ju något som är viktigt och bra som folk efterfrågar.
Det är ju liksom det första, det behövs.
Det är ett stort behov av det vi gör.
Sen är en anledning att vi styr stilen, vi till och med backar.
Och den har gränt mig.
En av mina styrkor är att jag tittar framåt, framåt, framåt.
Jag försöker dra lärdomen bakåt, men jag grämmer mig.
Åh, en sak jag ångrar säger folk ofta.
Så det är liksom inte lönt att lägga tid på det.
Men en liten grej som grämmer, det var ju att vi har ju vuxit alla år, redan ett år där vi tappade några hundratusen.
Det är väldigt större då.
Men det vi gjorde då, vi drog i handbromsen, vi sa upp halva personalstyrkan.
Det var inte roligt men det var tvunget.
Och så ställde vi om affärsmodellen helt enkelt.
Vi ställde om till den medlemsabinemangbaserade intäktsmodellen med kommission.
Och det gjorde vi då.
Och det som funkar bra var att det är det som tar oss mot lönsamhet.
Det är det som differensierar oss mot.
Kanske många investerare har sagt att bygger ni ett nytt mathem?
Nej absolut inte.
Mathem har en helt vanlig matbutik och gjort den online.
Men vi bygger något helt annat.
Vi bygger en plattform och en tjänst åt producenten som de får betala för att använda.
Och den omställningen gjorde vi 2024 och den börjar i effekt 2025.
Det är externa faktorer som att det var våren 2025 hade vi det här som kallades matboikotten där man inte skulle handla på, man skulle boikotta matbutiker och så vidare.
Det är klart att det gav oss ett litet uppsving.
Vi gjorde crowdfunding som gjorde att vi fick in ett större community med folk som handlar.
Men också för att vi har gjort tjänsten bättre så fler producenter vill sälja och fler producenter vill nå ut till fler och få ett redan sortiment.
Jag tror att vi gör rätt bra grejer av Oscar.
Vi har ett fantastiskt team med hela gänget här, men just Oscar som är vår helt ensamma.
Det är lite one man show när det kommer till utvecklingen.
Med de resurserna vi har och de pengarna vi har lagt ner på detta så har vi också börjat bygga en ganska fantastisk lösning.
Han är grym så vi gör mycket bra och vi gör mycket rätt.
Hade jag bara kunnat få dem alla jävlar som tycker detta är bra att handla så hade det varit guld och grönarskoga.
Om det kommer riktigt stora aktörer som hade kapital att driva igenom detta under 15-20 år, och du visste att de skulle göra ett snällt jobb eller ett gott jobb, hade du kunnat tänka dig att bara sälja över och lämna bolaget då?
Ja, jag har ju fått en fråga om och innan du har svaret har alltid varit nej, för det kändes liksom som det mest rätta svaret.
Jag vill påverka branschen, jag vill få liksom, det är ett sådant problem med oligopolet, att alla pratar om det när ingen hör.
Jag sitter på scen ibland, de sitter i publiken, ingen vågar säga, sen kommer de fram efter oss och gör en liten kolla som ingen kollar.
Jättebra det här, hur skitbra du vågar säga det.
Det tycker jag är så shitlandat bra, den här som rör om i grytan och vågar göra det.
Därför, och risken är ju så funkar det i branschen, på nedan en liten aktör som är duktig så köps de upplast upp och antingen läggs de ner eller så tastar över och så paketeras det in i de egna varumärkena.
Så att, men med det här lilla tilläget du hade, som är snäll.
Ja exakt, men du fattar vad jag menar, någon som står utanför.
Det är det någonting vi behöver, så är det musk.
Alltså vi behöver långsiktigt, en långsiktighet i det vi gör.
Vi behöver tillgång till kapital över tid, som förtar tid att generera utväxling liksom.
Så att, och det tyckte jag att man läser in i din fråga här, med det exemplet.
Och då skulle jag säga att ja, absolut är det det som krävs.
För det tråkiga är att vi ska bli lönsarna snabbt här nu.
Så alla signaler sett till hur siffrorna ser ut i dagsläget, så är det att övergå till helt vanliga retail-modellen som alla andra.
Och då är det bättre att jag lägger min tid på något annat.
För jag tror på alternativet.
Du, jag är förlåt fan, jag plöjde på här nu lite grann, men du nämner oligopolet här, och då pratar vi väl om ICA, Coop och Willys.
Är det jag pratar om också?
Ja, Axfood och Willys, ja.
Amla matupp och trev.
Vad är liksom, kan de ändra sig, eller är man liksom fast i en modell som är körd i och med att man har den konkurrenssituationen som man har idag?
Hade de i teorin kunnat ställa om någonting mot producenter, eller blir det bara att man förlorar då?
Måste det komma in en ny aktör i det jag menar, eller hade någon av dem kunnat ta den rollen?
En 10 000 kronor fråga.
I rimligtvis sett vilken kapacitet de har, vilken räckvidd de har, vilken närvaro de har, så är det så varat en vorde kunnig.
Men vi ser till den fjärde aktören som inte nämns oftast när vi pratar om oligopolet, det är ju Lidl.
Någonstans, dessa siffror får man ta med en nypa salt här, men jag läste någonstans, 13-14 miljarder etableringskostnad, och så står man för ett par procent av marknaden.
Det är så sjukt kostsamt att ta sig in.
Jag vet inte hur många miljarder de har tagit in, och så omsätter de inte ens två, efter alla detta år och tjänar inte pengar.
Att gå in och göra något med samma modeller på samma sätt, det verkar ju uppenbarligen inte vara rätt väg.
Så svaret är väl att det behöver nog komma med någon helt annan modell och ett helt annat mindset från gärna någon helt annan bransch tror jag.
Gärna från den hälsingborgska skogsmyllan någonstans där.
Ja.
Jag förstår.
Jens, stort stort tack för att du var med i podden.
Tack så jättemycket Johan.
Vi kommer att balla grejer, det kommer en trollkarl helt plötsligt då.
Flöken rum.
Det var ännu lite roligt, det blev förhandlingar, det blev lite suramin och mellandrakarna.